distinguished guests please welcome the
recipients of the 2023 International
women of Courage award
Professor Danielle Darwin
is
here
Brigadier General bowler gone gold
Mysteries Rios
Dr zakira hekmont
miazza Mohammed
Mrs Bianca zalevska
Mrs Yulia payevska
and representative keynote speaker for
the 2023 International women of Courage
award
Senator Roz adiba radzi
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
distinguished guests please welcome
today's presenters U.S ambassador to the
United Nations Linda Thomas Greenfield
White House Press Secretary Kareem
Pierre
deputy secretary of defense Kathleen
hooks
under secretary for civilian security
democracy and human rights at the U.S
Department of State azra Isaiah
an acting Ambassador at large for Global
women's issues at the U.S Department of
State cat photovat
[Music]
foreign
distinguished guests please welcome the
first lady of the United States Dr Jill
Biden
accompanied by U.S Secretary of State
Anthony blinken
foreign
[Music]
good afternoon everyone please take a
seat
and it is a special
honor for me to be able to say welcome
to the White House
[Applause]
and welcome especially to the 2023
International women of Courage awards
ceremony to all of you participating
here in person and tuning in from around
the world
for 17 years now U.S secretaries of
State have recognized International
women of Courage who are leading the
charge for Progress around the world
this year for the first time
we honor the awardees here at the White
House
and that really is a reflection of just
how highly
President Biden
first lady and this Administration
prioritize gender equality and human
rights
um Dr Biden thank you for bringing us
here today uh but thank you more than
that for everything that you're doing
every single day
to be such a remarkable role model to so
many women around the world
and for your incredibly tireless efforts
to lift up the voices of Brave women
everywhere around the world
[Applause]
so we're joined today by ambassadors
from across the globe who are essential
Partners in all of our efforts to make
sure that women and girls can reach
their full potential we have senior
leaders from across the United States
government here Ambassador Linda Thomas
Greenfield our champion our voice at the
United Nations
deputy secretary of defense Kath Hicks
under secretary Staters Isaiah our
advocate for human rights
Jen Klein cat photovat who are leaders
of our Global Gender policy and of
course White House Press Secretary
Kareem Jean-Pierre also such a powerful
voice for our country and for this
Administration around the world
and I also want to point out our team
from the Bureau for educational cultural
Affairs we're working with so many of
you every single day in the work that
you're doing uh we're also joined by
members of the state Department's
locally employed staff
um they're literally the lifeblood of
our missions in every country in the
world to be here today some of them have
traveled from more than a dozen
countries in Asia Africa Europe South
America and the Middle East it's
wonderful to be with you today as well
thank you
and in the audience we have several
previous winners of the international
women's courage award who are continuing
their inspiring work and the first lady
and I had an opportunity to greet them
to be able to say in person what we were
not able to do the last couple of years
which is congratulations and thank you
for the incredible work that you're
doing
[Applause]
and of course
last but not least
our guests of honor this year's
International women of Courage welcome
to all of you
when Secretary of State Condoleezza Rice
launched this initiative in 2007.
she did so to honor women creating
brighter futures for themselves
for their communities
and for generations to come
since then this award has recognized
more than 180 women from over 80
countries around the world and that
includes this year's honorees 11 truly
extraordinary people
as you'll hear
these women are reporting on Russian
atrocities in Ukraine
they're fighting for equal opportunities
for women girls in Mongolia they're
defending democracy in the Central
African Republic
they're protecting indigenous land in
Costa Rica they're advocating for the
rights of refugees people with
disabilities the lgbtqi plus community
because of their work
and even
as they do it every single day they are
faced with extraordinary challenges that
as you learn about them read about them
are humbling they
their loved ones in many cases
have endured harassment
they've endured violence
some have been imprisoned
others have been subjective
misinformation and online attacks day in
Day Out
and yet each and every one
has refused to be intimidated
in every region there are other women
doing this work
who we can't name individually in some
cases because the attention would put
them at even greater risk
so we found a new way to honor them this
year we're launching a group award named
after a Pioneer and champion of equality
the great secretary of state Madeleine
Albright
we have
[Applause]
several members of the Albright family
here today to help us celebrate I like
to think I'm an extended member of that
family
for me as I've as I've told our friends
I hear Madeline's voice in my head on a
regular basis the clarity
with which she spoke and what she said
continues to resonate and continues to
inspire me in the work that I and my
team are doing but you're you honor us
with your presence today thank you for
being here
around the world women in all of their
diversity
are often the ones on the front lines of
change
and yet at the same time they face still
greater obstacles to their political
participation they experience
gender-based violence and human rights
abuses they hold less economic and
social power
we are committed to changing that
defending the rights of women and girls
is rooted in our democratic values of
Human Rights and fundamental freedoms
for all
and when we advance equality and defend
the rights of women we improve life for
everyone
when peace is forward for the
participation and the leadership of
women it's more likely to last we know
this from experience
closing the gender gap in the global
Workforce would add 28 trillion dollars
to the global economy
and as secretary Albright once said
we simply cannot build the future that
we want without the contribution of
women
that's why President Biden has made
gender equality and women's rights a
priority of our foreign policy
some of you know we recently launched
the first ever
cross-government strategy on women's
global economic security to try to help
reduce the enduring wage Gap to improve
access to well-paying jobs to dismantle
barriers to women's economic
participation
in December the United States also
updated our strategy to prevent and
respond to gender-based violence
globally including new efforts to expand
access to programs for historically
marginalized communities
we're also learning from
and teaming up with governments Civil
Society the private sector and other
countries to work toward gender equality
together including of course the woman
that we're honoring today
one of those women Hadi LaBelle Aziz
noted that when it comes to advancing
this struggle success is not about one
big Act
not about one victim heroism
but 100 small battles
to honorees the United States is proud
to be by your side as you and others
wage those hundred small battles day in
Day Out
and we will be there and be there with
you for the Long Haul
that includes of course the first lady
of the United States Dr Jill Biden thank
you first lady
thank you
and thank you secretary blinken Tony
when Joe selected you to be Secretary of
State he knew that we had much to do
abroad from putting diplomacy at the
center of foreign policy to rebuilding
our Global Partnerships
and with every challenge we faced you
have ensured that we're better able to
deliver for the American people because
we have our allies by our side your
integrity and statesmanship
have helped us rally countries to stand
with Ukraine against Russia's war of
aggression
strengthen our ability to respond to
Future Health emergencies and confront
the climate crisis
thank you for all that you do
as the secretary said we are joined by
leaders from around our country and
across the globe
so to all of the members of The
Diplomatic Corps here thank you for
joining us today
and uh as the secretary said the family
of the incomparable secretary Albright
is with us and I'm going to ask you to
stand
thank you
and they all came to help us carry on
her Legacy
and we have our gender policy Council
the first of its kind and other leaders
from across our Administration
audience is a testament to our national
commitment to gender equality around the
globe and the powerful influence of the
people we honor today women of Courage
right here in the East Wing we will tell
their stories of fearlessness resilience
and hope we will hear from them in their
own words and there are people outside
of this room who need to hear their
stories too the girls who will inherit
this world
the future engineer who loves exploring
who sees magic in mechanics and
technologies that connect us to each
other but is told there's no place for
you in the classroom
the future president or prime minister
who was told that her voice is too loud
or too bossy or too feminine whatever
that means
the child who lives in fear the star who
is told to hide her light the girl who
feels the smallness of the world closing
in afraid that her dreams are just too
big to carry alone
again and again and again
they wake up to find a world made for
someone else and watch their brothers
and their fathers and their uncles and
their neighbors rise and grow while they
are told to shrink
told that they're not good enough not
strong enough not worthy of the lives
that they dream about
but today we're here to tell girls
everywhere the truth that they need to
hear
yes you matter yes you can make a
difference and that's why we wanted to
bring the leaders we're honoring today
and the stories that they share to the
biggest stage we could
the White House
thank you for helping us do that
girls everywhere need to know that there
are women fighting for them and winning
opening doors transforming schools and
communities and governments building a
better world for all of us
and we're also here to say to their
brothers and their fathers and their
husbands and their friends
as much as we need women who are willing
to speak up we need more men who are
willing to listen and act
[Applause]
we need more men to hold each other
accountable when their sisters are being
hurt or left behind we need more men who
nurture families who feed and teach and
Mentor who builds safer communities we
need more men who know that caring
collaboration and kindness are signs of
strength not weakness men
we need you to support the women who are
fighting for their rights and to lift up
those who have been silenced
be partners be partners with women
become the men of Courage we need
only then will we be able to build a
world where men and women are equal and
all people are free
so to all the women whom we are honoring
today know that the um enormous good
you've done has no end it touches every
person who hears your story it
transforms us with New Hope
as you seek Justice speak out and pursue
peace you inspire others to find courage
within ourselves and rise to that same
call
and to every little girl who has
wondered
can I one person
One Voice
one girl fix what's broken
let the women that we celebrate today be
an answer to that question an
unequivocal yes
when you learn and explore when you
raise your voice when you move through
the world with your shoulders back and
your head held high
step by step you shift the ground
beneath you
draw straight from the women of Courage
who came before you share that strength
with The Sisterhood that surrounds you
and the ripples of that power will
transform our world
and as you take those steps as you grow
into the women you will be remember
you are never
alone thank you
[Applause]
please welcome under secretary for
civilian security democracy and human
rights at the U.S Department of State
azra Zaya
foreign
it takes courage to seek Justice when
the powerful stand against you
laws can protect the innocent or
persecute the oppressed
and when the rule of law becomes a tool
of tyranny or when the structure is in
place simply fail to live up to the
promise of equality fairness and
Humanity we appeal to a higher ideal
Justice
the women we honor today have worked
tirelessly to ensure that their nation's
legal systems protect all people no
matter their gender beliefs or
background
and when those systems cannot or will
not protect every citizen
they have fought to transform them
they've broken barriers risen to new
heights and inspired other young women
to follow their lead
because without women's rights
perspectives and participation there can
be no justice
but when we all have the opportunity to
shape our laws we create systems that
truly serve us all
foreign
[Music]
we started by one part-time lawyer one
legal aid and we grew into a nationwide
network of legal clinics to ensure that
everyone has the right to be protected
by the law
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
and now Dr Biden and secretary blinken
will present the awards
[Applause]
as the first woman to lead the Central
African Republic's constitutional Court
Danielle darlone became known as the
woman of iron for her refusal to be
intimidated she spent her career working
to ensure the law delivers justice to
all no matter their background and in
the face of enormous pressure to allow
the president to rewrite the
Constitution to give himself an illegal
third term she refused sacrifice in her
career
to safeguard the rule of law
as founder and executive director of
Jordan's justice center for legal aid
hadil Abdul Aziz provides legal services
to thousands of people every year who
wouldn't otherwise have access to a
lawyer she works to educate people about
their rights so that they know how to
protect themselves and are empowered to
do so
thank you
during political unrest in Kazakhstan
which resulted in death's incredible
reports of torture long-time civil
rights Advocate
used phone calls to expose human rights
violations during an internet blackout
she then founded a coalition to document
violations and provide legal and mental
health support to victims of torture and
abuse
[Applause]
please join me once more in
congratulating these incredible women
[Applause]
please welcome deputy secretary of
defense Kathleen Hicks
[Applause]
it takes courage to seek peace when you
are the target of violence
when Wars are waged when authoritarians
seek to consolidate power when conflict
uproots and displaces families women and
girls shoulder many of the costs and
consequences
those who wish to harm and turn their
violence on women and girls often do so
because women and girls serve as a
society's source of strength and a
Beacon of Hope
it's because when women use their voices
to speak out against authoritarianism
their leadership can create lasting
Democratic change when women use their
voices to stand up for what's right
against overwhelming odds their voices
can reverberate around the world
and when women have a seat at the table
they hold the power to lead their
communities toward peace and prosperity
and that's the truth
studies show that when women participate
in peace negotiations these talks are
more likely to come to a just settlement
and result in lasting stability
peace is possible when we support the
women working to make it a reality by
stopping conflicts before they begin by
addressing the root causes of
discrimination and violence and by
working to end Wars that have already
begun and mitigating their harm
so today we salute several women leaders
who are exhibiting extraordinary courage
to seek peace when they themselves are
the targets of violence women who are
using their strength to pursue gender
equity and equality in the face of
extreme cruelty and Hate
women who are fighting for dignity and
freedom for not just themselves but for
others
in our awardees we see that our capacity
for understanding and healing is
stronger than the forces that try to
tear us apart and we are reminded that
women belong everywhere the decisions
are made
[Music]
the love suspect that my students gives
me was my courage to stand for the
voiceless women and children
[Music]
patients with disabilities of pwds have
the right to have good conditions in the
workplace to live independently to equal
opportunities to participate fully in
the life of their community
all of us
have a right to life without barriers
and it is Our obligation as a community
to ensure their full participation in
society on an equal basis with others
thanks to my work in a well-known
Morning Show I was able to collect a
large amount of humanitarian Aid which I
carried to the front line and I'm doing
this till today
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
on behalf of Dr Biden and secretary
blinken I'm honored to present Awards to
the following women
in Mongolia Brigadier General bolar
gonebold is the first female staff
officer in her country to be assigned to
United Nations peacekeeping operation
and the first female General to serve in
the Mongolian Armed Forces Brigadier
ganbold has served in peacekeeping
missions around the world and she's
advocated for gender equality and
peacekeeping forces and her country's
military so that women and girls can be
properly protected during and after
conflict
in Costa Rica Doris Rios has dedicated
her life to fighting for indigenous
women's rights to life and dignity and
for the Reclamation of indigenous lands
in the face of threats of violence and
attacks against her and her family she
has created a seat at the table for
indigenous women to make the world more
peaceful and just
in Argentina Alba ruata is a transgender
woman who was kicked out of classrooms
barred for sitting for exams refused job
opportunities subjected to violence and
rejected by her family but in the face
of these challenges she worked to end
violence and discrimination against the
lgbtqi plus community in Argentina
thank you
after women were barred from schools in
Afghanistan zakira hawkmat secretly
finished high school and won a
scholarship to study in Turkey
eventually becoming a doctor after
seeing the difficulty refugees face she
founded the Afghan Refugee solidarity
Association to advocate for the rights
of all refugees
it was my privilege and honor to uh to
honor each of you for your important
important contributions to human rights
and for making the world a more peaceful
place congratulations and thank you for
your courage
please welcome White House Press
Secretary Karine Jean-Pierre
it's courage to speak when those in
power want to stay want you to stay
silent
in a world where lies and Distortion are
easy to sell one of the most powerful
weapons that we have is the truth
because corruption thrives in darkness
dictators and authoritarians seek to
control criticism and Define the stories
that we tell
they threaten journalists and those who
speak out
so they can control knowledge and hide
their crimes
selling their people false stories of
peace and success
but when we illuminate the Shadows
we can expose the damage they create
lighting a path forward for those
trapped in the dark with the knowledge
and the strength to rise and demand
change
this group of journalists broadcasters
and War correspondents spread truth
courage and Empower other women and
girls to use their voices for democracy
freedom and justice
[Music]
depend on the country how much women are
participating in environment forces or
in the military but in the generally
around the world there are 15 to 20
percent of the women in the armed forces
being the women in the military is a
kind of broadly job
and the same as a man
is
naturales
[Music]
is
in Argentina
I believe that everyone in society has a
role to play in promoting their quality
and Justice and I know that my journey
has just begun
[Music]
and once again Dr Biden and secretary
blinken will present the awards
[Music]
through her independent YouTube news
Channel World hot TV veteran Ethiopian
journalist mihaza Muhammad share stories
of those who are often silenced despite
three arrests in under one year she
continued to raise her voice advocating
for survivors of gender-based violence
and urging accountability for crimes
committed against them
[Music]
while helping evacuate women and
children from areas affected by War
Ukrainian military veteran YULA payevska
secretly documented Russian forces
committed atrocities during the 2022
Siege of America
smuggled a memory card to the Associated
Press in a tampon and was forced to
destroy another with her teeth before
being captured by Russian forces and
tortured for information
since her release she has continued to
raise her voice for her people pushing
for peace and Independence for Ukraine
[Music]
now as a broadcaster journalist Raz
adiba radzi became a household name
after a car accident and brutal assault
permanently paralyzed her from the waist
down she used her platform to advocate
for the rights of persons with
disabilities
first as a reporter and now
as a senator in Malaysia's Parliament
and the first female chair of the
national Malaysian news agency bername
why polish generalists Bianca zaleska
was combating Russian misinformation in
2014 her car was shot causing accidents
that broke her spine since the Russian
invasion of Ukraine last year and in the
face of intimidation and death rest she
continues her work documenting war
crimes lifting up stories of refugees
and training other journalists to
effectively counter misinformation
please join me in a round of applause
for all of our awardees
thank you
please welcome U.S ambassador to the
United Nations Linda Thomas Greenfield
hello everyone
it really is a privilege to present this
new award
one that honors our first female
Secretary of State the late Madeleine
Albright
secretary Albright showed so many women
including myself how to lead with moral
Clarity and with courage
her Legacy lives on in those still
fighting for gender equality and
Universal human rights
it is fitting that this award recognizes
not just one woman but The Bravery the
fortitude and collaboration of a whole
movement it speaks to the outsized
impact of secretary Albright's example
and life of service
when the Albright family who is here
with us today learned about this award
they asked that another trailblazing
leader one who knew secretary Albright
well be part of this ceremony
secretary Condoleezza Rice
secretary rice created the international
women of Courage award in 2007 and
though she couldn't join us today she
wanted to take part in this very special
ceremony
I am humbled to be able to join you
today to honor an extraordinary group of
women the female protesters of Iran with
the Madeleine Albright honorary group
award
since the horrific death of Masa Amani
while in the custody of Iran's so-called
morality police women in Iran LED
protests across the country's 31
provinces and sparked months of
Grassroots support for women's rights it
is only fitting then that their
persistence and dedication is being
honored in the name of my late friend
Madeleine Albright
Madeline was a fierce fighter for human
rights for women's rights and for gender
equality around the world
she organized
foreign ministers women foreign
ministers to speak out about abuses in
Hidden corners of the globe
she made a difference in her commitment
to gender policy
we talked often about it
I tried to do the same as Secretary of
State
she was a fighter for equality
I am honored to congratulate the women
of Iran with the Madeleine Albright
honorary group award
thank you for your bravery compassion
and resilience you make all women proud
and and I wish they could be here to
hear your applause
I'm proud to present the Madeleine K
Albright honorary Group International
women of Courage award
this inaugural award goes to women and
girls in Iran who in the wake of the
brutal killing of masamini have inspired
us all
all Masa wanted was to live a normal and
happy life
she dreamed of starting a family after
finishing her studies
but these hopes and dreams were crushed
they were crushed by the tyranny of
Iran's so-called morality police
the Iranian government probably thought
this would just be another footnote in
the long record of violence and
discrimination against women
but this time
this time it was different
the Iranian people led by women took to
the streets in peaceful protest
they followed in the footsteps of Brave
women before them who sacrificed so much
in the name of freedom
through neighborhoods and classrooms out
of apartment buildings and car windows
the protesters chanted
throughout Iran and around the world
creating a global chorus demanding
gender equality and human rights
but for all the hope this movement
represents we must never forget how the
Iranian regime has responded
they have tortured peaceful protesters
they have arrested tens of thousands of
people they have badly injured and
killed Iranians in bloody crackdowns the
International Community must continue to
condemn the regime's repression and
violence and we must back up our words
with action
that's why the United States led a
successful effort to remove Iran from
the U.N Commission on the status of
women
and it's why we are working to hold
those complicit in these abuses
accountable
to all the women and girls across Iran
know this
we will continue to stand with you in
your fight for women for life and for
freedom
so everyone please join me in
recognizing the courageous women and
girls in Iran
thank you
I now have the honor of introducing
another courageous woman
who has been an unwavering Champion for
vulnerable populations in Malaysia
when a car accident and a brutal assault
paralyzed Senator Ross adiba razi
from the waist down she dedicated her
life to advocacy
to raise awareness Malaysians across the
country saw her on TV in Parliament and
at the Paralympics they heard her
commentary they heard her poetry
they heard her Fierce call for justice
in May 2020 she became Malaysia's
representative for people with
disabilities and later that year she was
appointed the first female chair of the
Malaysian national news agency Senator
Ross adiba razi embodies she embodies
what it means to live a life in service
to others please join me in welcoming
welcoming her to the podium
thank you
[Applause]
assalamualaikum of peace be upon you I'm
Senator rasa liberatzi a representative
of the 2023 International women of
Courage award before I begin
I would like to thank the First Lady
Dr Jill Biden the Secretary of State
Anthony J blinken and the U.S Department
of State for giving me the opportunity
to speak today I'd have to say that I'm
thoroughly impressed by the amazing work
done by my fellow finalists in The
respective countries let's give them a
big hand
among others I am joined by women who
are fighting against gender-based
violence for the rights of indigenous
persons and for the rule of law
honorable guests I was born able-bodied
and became permanently paralyzed from
the waist down after several incidents I
became a spinal cord injured person
following a car accident in 1995 a
brutal assault a year later and finally
in 2002 when I fell after climbing a
ladder since then I have committed my
life to fighting for the rights of
persons with disabilities in my country
Malaysia I witnessed discrimination and
stigma as a person's with disabilities
and then on my team and I
thought
and fought and fought
ladies and gentlemen
I have been working tirelessly to create
Awareness on the importance of
accessibility in infrastructure
disability inclusion job opportunities
inclusive education housing and
upholding our rights among others
I and my team then founded an
association to empower persons with
disabilities called oku Central in May
2020 the Malaysian King his majesty the
king of Sultan Abdullah appointed me as
a senator in the Upper House parliament
of Malaysia to represent persons with
disabilities
in November 2020 I was appointed the
first female chair of the Malaysian
national news agency banama after 53
years of its establishment
distinguished guests in the area of
sustainable development all of us here
aim to create a world which is inclusive
Equitable and sustainable a world in
which no one is Left Behind and
opportunities be made available for all
for secure stable and successful Nation
without the role and contribution of
women a nation will not be able to
progress as it is today
it is vital for all parties to respect
the contribution of women in all areas
economy social politics and culture
women's involvement is crucial as they
are an important asset to a country
so let's again give a big round of
applause and actually I feel like
hugging them all
especially to the women here and to
women all across the world who have
excelled in their roles and contributed
towards a prosperous Nation worldwide we
are at a pivotal moment for women's
rights for us receiving this
International women of Courage award is
very very much significant
for our people in each of our countries
this will be an integral part of
spreading awareness and will celebrate
the activism and transformative power of
women and goals honorable guests this
opportunity is indeed an honor for me to
share My Views and experience especially
concerning the protection and social
participation of persons with
disabilities in Malaysia with everyone
here today despite the increasing
awareness around persons with
disabilities there is no denial that
this discrimination
in this polarized World exists to the
Judgment of our disabled friends it
exists because of a prevailing mindset a
stereotypical way of looking at the
disabled
what the community needs to understand
and to accept is that persons with
disabilities are entitled to the full
range of civil cultural economic
political and social rights as stated in
various human rights instruments the
same as everyone else
on that note and as we speak the
Malaysian government is in the midst of
amending the persons with Disabilities
Act 2008 to have an anti-discrimination
act for persons with disabilities like
the United Kingdoms
and the Americans with Disability Act
1990 or Ada
estinges
raising awareness of basic human rights
and the right to be free of
discrimination among women children and
persons with disabilities is the
fundamental aspect in which we must
continue to work on without such
awareness it is extremely difficult to
bring about Justice and change the
increasing number of hate crimes racist
remarks and instances of ableist
Behavior shows that we must act quickly
to protect the most vulnerable
communities hence I would like to take
this opportunity to call on the
195 governments of the day in the world
to ensure that the marginalized and
vulnerable groups women children
including persons with disabilities are
not left out and rise to the Clarion
call of the 2030 sustainable development
agenda leave no one
no one behind
before I end my speech I'd like to
acknowledge the late Judith human a
leader in the disability Community
advocating for persons with disabilities
and has been the mother of the
disability rights movements since the
70s
we will miss her terribly
but myself
and the rest of us I promise you
will continue to be her voice
as she puts it we are leaders of
inclusiveness and community of Love
equity and justice
honorable guests
me standing here today in my standing
wheelchair
means a whole lot
especially for my countrymen Malaysia so
I'd like to say in Malay
which means a million prayers has now
reached the skies
or thank you for this honor
and from the bottom of my heart
foreign
acting Ambassador at large for Global
women's issues at the U.S Department of
State cat photovat
[Applause]
what an honor it is to close out such a
historic day such a historic event
happy International Women's Day to all
those around the world and to our
amazing women of Courage we honor today
what an incredible ceremony
I must say I am rendered nearly
speechless by the Senator's remarks your
resilience determination and Grit in the
face of extreme adversity and resolve to
continue to fight for women's rights as
human rights to achieve a better future
for us is both humbling and energizing
I couldn't also help but think of my
dear friend and personal hero
Judy heumann whose funeral I attended
just this morning
Judy was a leader of the international
Disability Rights Movement who said I
simply refused to accept what I was told
about who I could be
and I was willing to make a fuss about
it
through your work Senator and the work
of all of our awardees Judy's Legacy of
defending the rights and communities
facing discrimination will live on
you and all of our International women
of Courage awardees are truly
inspirational for your courage and as
Judy noted to make a fuss about it
I'm so honored to be here at the White
House today
to join first lady Dr Jill Biden
secretary blinken and the other
distinguished speakers who joined us to
pay tribute to the recipients of the
Secretary of State 2023 International
women of Courage Awards
the iwalk award is truly a centerpiece
and guiding force behind my office's
work to lead the department of state's
efforts to promote the rights and
empowerment of women and girls worldwide
and it is a Cornerstone of U.S foreign
policy and assistance
today our awardees join a truly
incredible group of more than 180 women
from more than 80 countries who have
received the international women of
Courage award since 2007.
in recognition of the exceptional
courage strength and Leadership all of
you have shown advocating for peace
Justice human rights and gender equity
and equality often at Great personal
risk and sacrifice
I hope this award will elevate your
advocacy work and bring in a greater
International attention to the issues
that you are fighting for
every day as my colleagues and I carry
out automation working with our partners
to prevent and respond to gender-based
violence Advance women's Economic
Security and promote the women peace and
security agenda across the globe we draw
inspiration from Fearless women's rights
Champions like the courageous women who
are we are gathered here to honor today
and also from their Advocates Defenders
their family members government allies
Civil Society leaders and journalists
who are also in this room today
championing gender Equity inequality
not just in words but in action
today on International women's day the
U.S government reaffirms our commitment
to the safety and full participation of
women and girls in decision making at
all levels and as foundational to peace
stability and economic growth of all
Nations
I'd also like to quote secretary
Albright who said it took me a long time
to develop a voice and now that I have
it I am not going to be silent
to our 2023 courage Awards
thank you again for using your voices
and being the voice for those who can't
use theirs let us all commit to using
our voices to amplify those facing
oppression crisis and in conflict in
places like Iran Ukraine and Afghanistan
and all over the world
congratulations to our awardees and
thank you for all you have done to give
women and girls everywhere a Fighting
Chance
we stand with you and for you
and thank you everyone here today
joining us to celebrate these truly
amazing and courageous women happy
International women's day thank you
[Applause]
distinguished guests please stay seated
while the awardees depart the stage
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you